hello everyone
and uh welcome to this talk i'm subha
thomas
i'm the developer of the microcontroller
kit
in this presentation i'll be going over
what's new in
2.0 of this kit and also a little bit on
what is planned for the immediate future
so let me start with an overview of the
microcontroller kit this is like
a 1000 foot view
in a nutshell the microcontroller kit
allows for the automatic generation and
deployment of code to microcontrollers
from the workflow language
and it does that in three steps so first
it generates the source code
and then it invokes a compiler and
compiles that code
and finally it invokes a programmer to
upload it to the microcontroller
so to use the microcontroller kit we'll
need three components
the first is the microcontroller kit
itself which is part of the wolfram
language since version 12
and then it is the compiler and
programmer tool chain
for most of the boards that we released
new in 2.0
the this tool chain is not part of the
standard arduino
ide but it's a very straightforward and
easy
process to actually get that tool chain
and i have provided the links for that
instructions and in the last slide
in case you do not have it and of course
you need the hardware
where where we are deploying the code
now all yeah so in case you do not have
the
the compiler or the hardware at the very
least you should be able to see the
source code
using the microcontroller kit so all
this is handled by
one function and that function is
microcontroller embed code
and it takes three arguments
the first argument is the systems model
itself or the core computation that you
want to do on the microcontroller
the second argument has to do with the
target it answers questions like what is
the microcontroller what are the input
channels what are the output channels
and so on
and the third argument is the mechanism
on how you can get that
compiled code onto the microcontroller
okay so in in version 1.0
we added support for 8-bit
microcontrollers like the atmega328
uh the atmega32 u4
and and a bunch of 80 tiny atmega tiny
families and that supported
microcontrollers like uh
the arduino uno the arduino micro the
arduino nano and so on
and subsequent to that release we
started gathering feedback
on what we should prioritize and based
on the external feedback
the arduino boards came out on top and
that's what we started
working on so one of the first things we
released in between what one and two was
the
atmega2560 which is the arduino
mega25 which is the microcontroller
between the behind the
mega 2560 we released this
sam 3 microcontroller family which
you know this one is part of version 2
which is behind the arduino duo
and the biggest and we have this one-off
microcontroller
from ti but the big chunk of
microcontrollers are the sam d21 and its
big brother samd51
so this is still an 8-bit but all the
others are 32-bit microcontrollers and
are much more powerful
they have more flash and higher
higher speeds than the 8-bit
microcontrollers that were part of
version one so all in all
in in in version 2.0 we have 36 new
boards
from various vendors like adafruit
arduino
and sparkfun the workflow the design is
very clean so the workflow for any of
these microcontrollers is the same
so it's going to be very easy to switch
from one microcontroller to the other
and all the workflows i show here today
will just carry over from one
microcontroller to the next
so let me start with the basic example
because first i'm going to load the kit
and in your next unix like operating
systems i can get the serial port
to which the microcontroller is uh
connected by looking at the dev
directory
uh def folder in the root directory so
if i value right now i have i don't have
my microcontroller connected
so
so this is the setup i'm going i've now
connected it
and so now if i evaluate this i should
see the port to which it was connected
so i take this basic example of blinking
an led
and this is the model that will blink
the led so this variable x is going to
be connected to that port
and if if x is a value greater than zero
it will
turn it low and for any other value it
will turn it high
and it's going to switch at this time
interval and that we get the blinking
led behavior so if i
if i evaluate that system and then the
second argument is the microcontroller
specification
i say what the target is and the output
i've connected to pin
three so let me evaluate that
and now if i yeah so this is also
something new in version
2.0 where we have this temporary cell
showing what the
what the status of evaluating that
function is
and now if i go there so this
this led i've connected it to pin three
and so this is the this is just a basic
example
so the workflow as i said is pretty much
the same
for for all the other basic examples too
so following that same usage of
microcontroller embed code
here i have i still have the output as
as the third pin the third uh digital
pin
but the input i'm going to take a
digital input from the fourth pin
my target is still the same and the core
computation is
one it's just a gain of one so whatever
input here i'm going to
send it out to the output so to do that
i'm going to
okay so i have to did not i do not have
it okay
okay i'm going to connect this um
encoder
so this encoder has three wires coming
out of it
so the let's see it
yeah so one is the can i put it yeah
one is the red which is the positive
then it's
the black the ground and the green is
the signal wire so i'm going to
connect these so i'm going to put the
red
on the positive black on
ground and i'm going to connect this
third lead
to pin 4 here
okay i got all that right
and now if i back now if i evaluate this
and
okay and so this is an optical encoder
here
okay i have this optical encoder here
now
as it is seeing this as it's coming in
view and it's not coming in view it's
sending a zero and one to pin one
and that is turning on and off the led
okay here i have analog output
so this one the reference voltage is 3.3
so if
if i send half that it's going to give
up a
pwm signal of 50 duty cycle
so no inputs just the output is an
analog output
so let me go back there okay so now that
one
just uploaded
yes so
yeah it's uploaded that code and
now this is at half half intensity
if i make it zero then that should turn
it off
let me see if that uploaded it yeah it
uploaded it and that one should
turn off so yeah
yeah so the reference voltage is
typically the
the maximum value that for which it will
turn the duty cycle on 100
but sometimes you may have a value that
is different
from the reference voltage and then you
can you can
so on all these examples this is just
a shortcut to specify it but the full
specification of any input output
channel is to say what the pin number is
say what type it is and
any other specifications here i want the
max value 10. if you have no other
specifications you can just say
the pin name is of type analog as i have
done here but here because i want to
give
an additional specification that's why i
give i gave the
full usage i use i use the full syntax
so now the maximum value is 10 so for 10
it should turn the led completely on
so let's see so now once that's uploaded
okay it's uploaded okay so that's
fully bright okay then we have
yeah now over here again i have an
analog
input connected to pin a0 and that
analog output i send out to
pin three so once that is uploaded
i should be able to adjust the
brightness of that led using
the potentiometer i have connected to
pin h0
okay so this is the potential meter i
have there
i have here and that i've connected to
a0 right there so i'm going to
turn this on and that should
so these are like building block
examples that you can use for
larger applications as well
and finally i also wanted to show serial
in this
this basic set of examples so in the
arduino so here
again i'm taking a serial input and
sending it out to the output
and again the gain is one so whatever is
coming in the input goes out
to the output okay and then on the
arduino 0
that the serial input and output that is
actually connected to my
uh computer is doesn't have a pin output
there so
we have to specify what that it is the
input rx and tx on the programming port
so once that is uploaded then i can
connect
any serial any device with the serial
input and output
and the microcontroller will be able to
talk to it but here i'm going to use the
device framework to send and receive
data so i open a connection
to that microcontroller my script u and
y variables i'm using to
get store the input and output variables
and then i create a
scheduled task object so if the if the
device is ready
i'm going to open to the output variable
the what it is reading and then the data
comes in as
a start byte the data and the end byte
so i terminate at the end byte
and then i'm just going to parse it once
i read it i flush the buffer
and then i create a input and send that
input back to the microcontroller
so now if i plot the input and output so
it's exactly one on top of
the other so that's where you see the
input and out the behavior like that
okay so now let's move on to external
libraries
so for anything that is not in the
um in the in the core code we have to
for any feature we want to use that is
not in the core
code or if you want to use any library
from github and so on there are tons of
those
that's where this feature of
incorporating the external libraries
becomes useful so because these external
libraries are not part of the core
the macro microcontroller kit needs to
know where this is where these libraries
are
and that we can give as an optional uh
that we can give the path to that we can
give in this as this specification in
the optional fourth argument
so once we have done that to incorporate
the code
we also need to know how the
microcontroller kit
actually generates the code when in the
pre in the previous
examples when we were saying that this
input is
pin for digital it generates code and
then puts
that in various sections of the final
code there'll be some code to initialize
maybe some code
that has to repeat and so on so when
we're using external libraries
these we give directly so instead of
saying
pin name and its specification we give
we directly say external libraries and
in what
segment sections of the code we want to
inject these values
so i also take this opportunity to say
that you can inject code like this
without tying it to any particular
external library you can just say
in this in the microcontroller
specification that you want to add
code at this and this location and it
will do it for you
okay so one of the things that the
arduino 0 has is
an i squared c peripheral so this is
uh the protocol for handling audio data
so what i have here is a microphone
from uh from adafruit and these are the
ground
and power lines and then
usually there are three lines for i
squared s so one is the
the clock line the other one is the
output from the microphone itself
and then the select line which selects
because this this is
it it comes as stereo and you can and it
will select
when the when the signal comes the
this this line will determine whether
it's on the left
or on the right so this select we have
just uh
uh not connected so by default there is
there's values coming i believe only on
the left channel
okay so let's see how we deploy code to
that so the code i have here okay
so i'm getting an input okay u is the
input here if i get an input
so if the value is minus one or zero
then i'm just going to
ignore that and use the previous value
but if it's
not then i shift it to the right
by by 14 bit so
so this is an approximation and for my
voice
for human voice this this approximation
is
is good okay yeah and
so this is another option x so now all
these variables will be stored as type
in so you can give
that option too so i'm going to do it as
an external library
so i say where the library is and then
now i'm going to inject code into
various parts of the
of the program so i say what files to
include how do i initialize it
so i initialize it in this mode with
this frequency and
this is the width of the word that's
coming in and then
this because it's an input channel
whatever is read the last
the last argument in loop gets assigned
to the input of
of the core computation
to that then the output i'm i'm sending
it over serial
and again that's of type int this
external byte i'm still trying to figure
out why
it needs that external byte to be 10 not
our standard one for
it to work so so then we i have the
microcontroller specification and now
i'm going to
deploy that
so as i said the data comes in as a
start byte
yeah and then the rest of the data and
this is the function i just wrote a
small function to parse the data
i open the connection to the device
and here i'm not writing any of the
device i'm just reading
from the buffer and now if you see
yeah so as i talk this is the
values it is picking up
and and so the thing about this result
is that
it's it's picking up at every sampling
period maybe i should just let it run
it's picking up at every sampling period
so
it's not really measuring uh how loud i
am because it's missing things so too
so to address that
what what we can do
[Music]
we have the same we have the same
model as before where where we shift the
input by 14 bits to the right and then i
have this model
which takes a sample of uh 0 to 127 so
128 values
and then it computes the maximum and
minimum of
those values to see this in so all the
rest of this little
code till here you do not need to deploy
code is just to show what is happening i
have a bunch of ranges
and this is a utility to create a list
of random
reels now this is the if i send this
input into that model
okay and then if i compute the output
response
what it is doing is it's computing the
the difference between
the max and the min that's the peak to
peak
of the output signal so in the first
range 0 to 10 and this is the value for
max to min
and so on so i put this together
and then this is the same as before i
i have the the header files to include i
start the i square this uh interface and
then i start reading
oh this is same as before and then yeah
so here i forgot to mention
the output yeah so at after 127
after 128 samples it returns the
difference between the max and the min
but otherwise it returns a value of -1
and that's what we see here
it's returning a value of -1 and after
128 samples
it returns the difference between max
and min
so i have this post-loop
code so if that value is not minus one
if the value is minus one it's still
computing so we don't
output that but if it's not it outputs
to serial
and that together makes the all that
together makes the microcontroller
specification
and i'm going to embed that
so it's uploading
yeah okay
just as before i have a function to
parse the data
i open yeah so the other thing i did
here that's different from before is
i i increase the baud rate
the speed at which it is because we
don't want to miss
any of those values so i set up a
scheduled task
so this one is okay over here i say i
have two schedule tasks one this one is
a fast
task so this is just getting the values
and i have a second schedule task which
which makes sure that that value doesn't
uh go above a certain value
so this technique you can use so when
you want to get something over serial
and then you want to do something else
which is not so
time critical you can set up like a
bunch of scheduled tasks
and one is really fast in particular and
that's where it's getting the data and
something else you can do it much slower
okay now i submit those tasks
now it should pick up my sound level so
i'm going to remain silent for a minute
for just for a moment
okay i'm going to say hello okay
i'm going to try to do it a bit louder
hello
yeah so it's working as we expect
okay okay so now so
so far i had uh i squared as uh
as an input now now i have some examples
where we
where we have i squared as an output so
here there is an amplifier
okay i have to first plug this in
okay let me let me get rid of all these
yeah so that's the speaker and this is
that
amplifier and
this is that amplifier end and dac
connector
and so now i have to connect these pins
according to
this one so one wire
is the
okay so i have to okay
yeah okay
let me go back so you see what i'm doing
okay so the output of
this the positive i connected to this
switch so yeah it can get
quite noisy so i have a switch there
which i can turn on and off
and the next wire i have let me bring it
in the shot
as the ground wire
the next one over here is the data line
which i connected to pin nine one is the
it's the clock line which i connect to
pin zero
and finally this one
okay let's go back and make sure
yeah so again over here i have a data
line
and then there's the clock line and this
one which selects with
selects where the left channel is coming
in and where the right channel is coming
and these two pins i leave by default so
the gain is how loud you want the
amplification and
this one is for shut down and how how it
mixes the left and right channels by
default it's just
averaging those two channels so let me
deploy this code okay let me
so here this model here is
uh is the model for a sinusoid because
it has no damping terms
so if you look at the output response of
this it's two sinusoids
and i'm going to discretize this model
and then i connect it to another model
so this value i
chose which is
just the volume based on if you make it
too loud and
can hurt or yes or it can be quite
annoying
okay and we connect these two and then
we put them in in series
okay so we're going to now do a similar
thing so for this
it has a different library that is
supplied by adafruit
so i say i this is the path to that
library
these are the files to include and i
create this i squared s
object 0 1 9 and 12 are the
pins you're not really using pin 12
which is uh
data out but we uh
we're using the the other three pins
and then we begin this as a uh
though each word is 32 bits and this is
the frequency and then i enable
transmission
transmission so again because this is an
output
so this int left gets assigned
to this first output
okay and i put all those all that code
along with that left channel
and then the in right as the second one
the second output
so because this is the first one that
gets assigned the second output gets
assigned to intro
and once i have left and right then i
can i can write it out to the device
and that's the second channel and this
gives the
complete microcontroller specification
okay so let me
deploy that
oops i had turned it off so let me turn
the microcontroller back on
okay so that's deployed yep
so now if i turn this on you should hear
a sinusoid
okay let me bring the speaker close to
my microphone okay
i hope you hear that sinusoid by the way
i think i'm running out of time also
let me turn that guy off
okay okay so this i'm just
i think i'm going to just gloss over the
next two slides so what i wanted to do
was i
use um
use the potentiometer as an input and
create a
varying sinusoid output i wanted to
adjust the value of the
of the the value of the frequency of the
sinusoid and that is
this uh this example
so i'll just leave it here because i
don't think i have time to
go over that and the next one the next
example i
show is how to deploy
code for audio that is based on just
bitwise operations
so so so what i'm showing here what i
have here as the examples
uh in this notebook are just basic
building blocks and we should be able to
take them and create much more
interesting applications with these
okay okay let me quickly say what's
coming in
3.0 so so far
okay so so far we have
support for for eight a few eight bit
microcontrollers and
now we have uh support for 32-bit
microcontrollers
okay so we thought it was a good time
to actually polish up some of these
internal functions
and expo and release it so
so somebody externally can also uh add
uh
add support for various microcontrollers
because as i was developing this
i saw that there are like
microcontrollers
that are very close it just needs a
little work
to get it to to get it up and to get
into
integrated with the microcontroller kit
okay so you don't have to like wait for
us to like release it i mean it should
so these one-off things so if you want
you can also
just develop your own uh uh
support based of the microcontroller
okay so we had
we're going to add a bunch of functions
in this developer context
that helps you to add microcontrollers
microcontroller families
and i mean we support some menders you
can also add
new vendors so how so if you look at
the pro the
what the microcontroller kit is using
internally for like arduino 0 it's using
the the the data for this
microcontroller is stored in this
variable
okay see so that's how it knows whether
the pins you specified is correct
and so on so you can add this yourself
now once we expose these symbols
so i assign this to this variable
foo and then i just create my own
microcontroller based on that
and now this microcontroller is uh
it's a new microcontroller although in
this case it's very trivial it's just a
repetition of that but
you can go ahead and add a
microcontroller a new microcontroller or
a family like that and then the
microcontroller kit will pick it up and
generate code for that okay
okay so to summarize the microcontroller
kit is a tool that enables you to take
wolfram language code and deploy them to
microcontrollers in this version 2.0
we've added support for microcontrollers
belonging to samd21 samd51 and sam3
families
so you can generate and deploy code
using the standard features
external libraries and also custom
symbolic c code
and the coming developer tools provides
functionality to add support for
new microcontrollers so this is the link
to the microcontroller kit itself and
various links to set up the tool chains
for
for the boards that we support okay so
i think i conclude my talk with that i
hope you found this talk uh helpful
i'm really out of time so if there are
any questions just
send them my way on pathable and i hope
you find this functionality
useful in your projects thank you